- [Announcer] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website, or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape;
bipedal, naked large-brained. Lone the
master of fire, tools and language. But
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable, yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here. An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Brenna] Thank you so much for
having me. So, unlike most of your other
speakers, I actually work with
contemporary humans and not fossils, but I
will try to maintain your attention
anyway. I am mostly interested in human
evolution. And as you've noticed from
these diagrams that people have put up
regarding the phylogeny of Neanderthals
and Denisovans and modern humans, modern
humans often get represented as sort of
just a single branch, or maybe a few
genomes that come off this other branch.
And so what I want to do is really take a
little bit of time and conceptualize what
it means to refer to the Homo sapiens as a
single species. Did we have a single
origin. There's actually a lot of
complexity in this question which isn't
necessarily addressed by one of these
simple tri-part type phylogenies. So,
let's just break down kind of the known
working model we have for human evolution
which is mostly based on contemporary DNA.
So, if we start out in Africa roughly
about 100,000 years ago. I'm an advocate
of a Southern African origin. I'm not
going to try to convince you of that
today, but we actually don't know where in
Africa. There was a single origin of the
Homo sapiens species if indeed it was a
single origin model, all right? And then
from Southern Africa, putatively, there is
a migration and dispersal into the rest of
the African continent. And certainly by
60, maybe even slightly earlier, 70,000
years, there were these individuals living
in Northeastern Africa at which time there
was what we call a "founder event." So,
these populations moved out of Africa into
the near East. Now, this event is actually
a major event in human evolution, or at
least in the genomes of all non-Africans
living today. And that is because there
was a strong reduction in genetic
diversity during this founder event. And
that's indicated here by the fat arrow,
okay? So every time you see a fat arrow on
this map, that indicates a reduction in
genetic diversity. Once humans left
Africa, these individuals spread rapidly
across the Eurasian continent. There are
some hypotheses of what they call the
South Indian or South Asian migration
route which is along the coast of the
Indian subcontinent, and eventually into
Southeast Asia and Oceania, certainly by
45,000 years ago. As well as additional
migrations into Northern Asia and
eventually into the Americas where it was
accompanied by yet another strong founder
event or population bottle neck which
reduced the genetic diversity of those
populations. And we'll hear a little bit
more about that today from Maria. So
that's our basic model of human evolution
over the last 100,000 years. But you'll
notice that there's not a lot of detail in
Africa, actually. There's just a few
arrows and some general little dates.
Geneticists love to put arrows on maps and
I am no exception. So, I'd like to instead
think about posing this question, "Where
in Africa did humans originate?" And there
are different types of genetic evidence or
other types of evidence one might use to
answer this question. And there's a sort
of presentation here. This is by Batini
and Jobling where they suggest different
types of evidence one could look at. So
you could look at for example, non-genetic
evidence, skulls that have been
dug up from the ground by
paleo-anthropologists. You could look at
evidence of what we call
"symbolic behaviors,"
such as the making of art,
so shell beads
or these little crosshatch ocher pieces
that have been discovered. You might even
look at language. So there's a really
fascinating paper from a few years ago
that looked at phonemic diversity, not
genetic diversity, but looking at the
number of phonemes in different languages
and can we learn anything about the
origins of language by the amount of
diversity that's present in phonemes? And
he argued, indeed, Africa has the highest
phonemic diversity. And in particular even
Southern African has the highest phonemic
diversity. So I'm a geneticist. I focus on
a different type of evidence and you can
break down genetic evidence also into
these little patches. So one might be the
mitochondrial DNA. Mitochondrial DNA, as
we've heard from other speakers, is
something that's inherited through the
maternal lineage. So the mother passes it
on to her children and then it's passed on
from the daughter to her children.
Alternatively, you could look at the
Y-chromosome which has a different pattern
of inheritance from father to son, and so
on and so on, for many generations. And
then last are what we call the autosomes,
which are the remainder of the chromosomes
1 through 22 that compose the rest of your
genome. So when this was done, and this
slide is a little bit dated, but from
mitochondrial DNA and Y-chromosome DNA, it
was a little bit hard to pin-point
precisely where the deepest divergence was
within Africa, I'm going to address that
again later, but at least from the
autosomal information. Both if you look at
SNPs or a single-nucleotide polymorphism,
just your vanilla mutation. They actually
have the highest genetic diversity, or
heterozygosity, in Southern African
populations and even other types of
polymorphism like microsatellites also
look like they had the highest diversity
in Southern African populations. And so
we're getting a lot of conflicting pieces
of information maybe from non-genetic
evidence, from genetic evidence. So how
can we sort of conceptualize synthesizing
all this information? So I'm actually an
anthropologist by training, despite the
fact that I do genetics, and so I like to
sort of begin with the paleo-anthropology
and that's what we're going to do right
now. So there's a fantastic amount of
information that's been excavated from the
fossil record. And some of this
information comes in the form of bones,
right? Like we've seen earlier on the
talk. And on the right here, you have a
fossil cranium from Hurso, Ethiopia that
was dug up. And it looks
like...morphologically, it's very similar
to modern humans. So the front part of the
skull is actually tucked in underneath the
brow ridge. The skull is actually pretty
short from front to back. The brain size
is of course equivalent to what you would
see in contemporary human populations
today. And if we put flesh on this
individual, they would probably look
relatively similar to other human sapiens
around the world. However, so we know that
there was morphologically individuals that
were probably similar to Homo sapiens
walking around Africa at least 150,000
years ago. But in fact there's a lot of
additional information that can be gleamed
from stone tools. So, there is a phrase
that's called the "middle stone age." And
the middle stone age refers, at least
roughly to 250,000 years ago to 50,000
years ago. And on this other map, what you
see are sites in Africa where middle stone
age artifacts have been recovered. So we
know that hominin populations were living
in these areas of Africa during this time
period.
And what you'll notice, right, is that
there is maybe not that many examples of
this beautifully reconstructed skull from
all over Africa, but there are many, many
geographic locations on this map that
actually date back to the middle stone
age. And so what does that mean? So that
means of course that there were lots of
hominins walking around the face of Africa
during this time period. And in fact there
is also good evidence from North Africa as
well, even though it's cut off in this
particular map. And so let's just kind of
make a little schematic and start to think
about this. So if I look back into Africa
150,000 years ago, 200,000 years ago, I
know that there are Homo sapien-like
populations, broadly speaking, that exist
in different parts of the landscape. And
so we can ask a relatively simple
question, "Were these populations
structured?" That means, are they
different from one another? So perhaps we
have populations in North Africa, East
Africa and Southern Africa. There is less
information from Central Africa for
various reasons. And these environments
may have been very different from one
another. So you might have had a cool,
Mediterranean climate up in North Africa
and then a very hot desert-like climate,
let's say, in Southern Africa. And the
question then is, are these populations
really separate from one another? Or are
individuals moving in between them? So
population geneticists like to refer to
this concept as population structure. So
let me just explain what that is briefly.
In this little schematic, we have a SNP,
or a single nucleotide polymorphism up on
the top that either comes in red or
yellow. And we have two populations on
either side of this river and we can see
that they are very different from one
another. So individuals on one side of the
river carry only the red allele, and
individuals on the other side of the river
only carry the yellow allele. And this is
structured populations, or populations
where there are strong differences in
allele frequency. And this is in contrast,
down to the bottom, of populations which
are carrying both the purple and the
orange alleles because there is migration
between these two populations or gene
flow, if you refer to your little glossary
on the handout, and this is because I've
given them a nice little bridge so people
can walk across and migrate. So, we
can just sort of take that example and
apply it to the rest of Africa as well.
So, were these populations structured at
200,000 and 150,000 years ago? Or was
there actually what we call "panmixia" or
lots of migration among the different
sup-populations? And I think we have an
actual answer to this particular question,
but it's somewhat complicated to infer in
fact. And one thing to point out is that
in either of these scenarios, if you're
thinking back to what the landscape would
have looked like 200,000 years ago, means
that if I went and sampled individuals
from across the African landscape, their
common ancestor, in terms of their
genetics, would have been very old. It
would actually pre-date 150,000 years ago
or 200,000 years ago. In order to
understand why that is, you have to again
take a little mini-class in population
genetics here and think about the
difference between populations and genes.
So this is what we call a "gene genealogy"
which is represented by these little
lineages right here. And these lineages
exist within these two different
populations, okay? So we can sort of trace
back the common ancestry of a given
genetic segment to where that individual
shares a common ancestor. And these common
ancestors exist in some ancestral
population which I'm going to then let
evolve through time. So now, we have this
common ancestral population and there's
been some sort of divergence and is
diverging to the blue and orange
populations. And you can see that these
gene genealogies, these genetic lineages
are sort of splitting nicely into the blue
and orange population. And then finally,
at the present day, or down here. You
know, I might go and sample individuals
from the orange population, and the blue
population and then ask when their common
ancestor was, okay? And that common
ancestor is indicated up here just like in
a normal phylogeny. The key thing to
remember actually when you're looking at
that is that the common ancestor pre-dates
the population divergence, okay? And this
is the case for most of the low side that
we would look at in the human genome. So,
the common ancestor must be older than the
population divergence. So then, we can
ask, "How old are the common genetic
lineages within human population?" So I'm
going to do this for a relatively simple
locus, the Y-chromosome, right? So the
Y-chromosome again is just passed on
between father and son. And one of the
nice things about the Y-chromosome is that
it's relatively small, so it's easy to go
in and sequence it from many individuals.
So, a few years ago, we captured about 10
megabases of the Y-chromosome from a
variety of individuals across human
populations and we actually had a strong
focus here on sampling African populations
because that's what I'm obsessed with, is
African populations. And what you'll see
is all the African individuals are sort of
on the bottom half of this segment and
you're just looking at a normal gene
genealogy or phylogeny that's been flipped
on it's side. So the common ancestor is
right here and then each one of these
lineages represents a single individual's
Y-chromosome that was sampled from a man.
Now the first thing obviously to notice is
that individuals from outside of Africa
have very little genetic diversity on
their Y-chromosomes compared to
individuals from Africa. And you can
easily see that by their relatively short
branch lengths up here. So these are all
the out of African individuals, okay? So
people from Cambodia, people from the
Americas, people from Europe and so on.
And instead if I look within Africa, I see
individuals that carry really, really long
branches, okay? So for example,
individuals from West Africa and North
Africa diverge around here. And
individuals that are from these African
hunter-gatherer populations, which are
particularly special, carry
extraordinarily long branches all the way
back to the common ancestor. So that graph
can be a little bit hard to read for some
people who are not geneticists so I've
tried to make a schematic. If we look at
the time to the common ancestor and we try
to date in years how long ago that might
have been, we can kind of put an upper
bound on the population divergence among
all human populations. And so when we do
this with the Y-chromosome, what you
actually see is that the upper bound on
population divergence would have been
around 150,000 years ago plus or minus a
couple of tens of thousands of years,
okay? So we're actually seeing relatively
shallow divergence among contemporary
human populations. And with a little bit
of additional modeling we can actually
say, "Well, which population diverged
first from all other human populations and
when was that?" And at least looking at
the Y-chromosome sequence it's most likely
to have been these Khoisan populations
from Southern Africa and we date it to
approximately around 90,000 years ago.
Now, you could say, "Well that's just the
Y-chromosome. It's just a single locus and
has this bizarre pattern of inheritance
from father to son." So independently,
there was additional papers published by
Renaut [SP] and also Veeramah
approximately about a year before we
published our Y-chromosome work, and they
actually independently came up with a very
similar estimate on this time of
population divergence between these
Southern African hunter-gatherer groups
and the other humans within Africa. And
that time of population divergence is
approximately 100,000 to 120,000 years
ago. So again, what you're seeing is that
the gene genealogies certainly go back in
time, but the actual time depth of this
population divergence is quite shallow,
okay? And if we try to map that on to
these sort of schematics of Africa, what
would that mean? It means that neither of
those two maps that I showed you before
could really represent the actual true
ancestors to the human population. So
something must have happened to reduce the
genetic diversity between 200,000 years
ago and 100,000 years ago. And so let's
just think for a moment what that might
have been or what that could have looked
like. So one hypothesis could be that
there was a strong population bottle-neck
during this time period, 200,000 to
100,000 years ago. And maybe that
bottle-neck was associated for example
with climate. So populations actually
could have moved from one region to
another because of climatic fluctuation.
And in this case, I've had all the
individuals that are living in Eastern
Africa and Northern Africa just sort of
trickle down and move into Southern Africa
where things were nicer during that time
period. That doesn't have to necessarily
be the only location, it's just one
example. This movement into a refugium
would likely have been accompanied by a
population bottle-neck as you can imagine.
If things are stressful in a given
environment then usually what we see is a
reduction in population size. Conversely,
you could also think about it in a
slightly different way, maybe there was
some stressful climatic experience and
that these other populations simply went
extinct, okay? So you have local
extinction events for example here in
Eastern Africa, or Northern Africa, and
only a population persists in one
geographic region again indicated here by
these little Xs in Southern Africa. Then
what would have happened, right? So then
at a 100,000 years ago, we know humans
began expanding again. So if they did sort
of localize to one specific place on the
African continent, what would that then
look like?
They would have expanded into these
other regions again but maybe they absorb
individuals that persisted there. So maybe
there wasn't complete extinction events in
these other geographic regions, or indeed
maybe all these individuals that were
living in Eastern and Northern Africa did
completely go extinct and we don't see
their signatures in the human genome. So
this I want to sort of end by emphasizing
that this is a single origin model for the
modern human species, but it fits the data
actually quite nicely because of this
shallow divergence we see in the genetic
lineages. And I will emphasize that there
is a lot of additional sequencing that
needs to be done particularly in African
populations were we probably have the
fewest samples of full human genomes that
have been sequenced. And we really need to
actually think explicitly about testing
these models in a context that connects
the genetic data with the
paleo-anthropological information. And I
will stop right there. Thank you very
much.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Johannes ] So thanks for the
invitation. So I would like to talk today
about a more recent chapter in human
history. So we have heard a lot about the
early chapters of human history today
about the early evolution of modern humans
in Africa and also about the interaction
between archaic humans and early modern
humans. But I would like to talk today and
turn our focus from the ice age, the
Pleistocene, into the Holocene into the
last 10,000 years of human history and I
try to convince you that this is also an
extremely exciting time period where we
even see a lot of changes even in human
evolution into human phenotype in several
parts of the world. So as I mentioned,
we're actually living today in this time
period, the Holocene which is a time
period of relative climate stability, some
people might even say that we have
actually changed our environment so much
that we're now living in a time period
which we call the Anthropocene which might
have started in the last 2,000 years but
the main focus of this talk should really
be the Holocene, so the last 10,000 years
of human history. Most of this time period
actually we do not have historical
documents so we have no information that
people wrote down about human history in
this last 10,000 years where we usually
have to rely on archeological information
for example, or paleo-anthropological
findings, so human skeletons for example
that might tell us something about things
that changed in the past the same thing
for example like migration, genetic
admixture or the genetic turnover of the
human population. But we and others have
actually started in the last few years to
use genetic data to tell us something
about changes that happened recently in
our evolution or in human history and I
would like to focus my talk today about
one event that archeologists had already
identified many years ago and that is
probably the biggest change in human
history that happened in the last few
million years and it's actually the change
from the subsistence strategy of hunting
and gathering, to Neolithic farmers that
relied on agriculture and started to
domesticate animals. And this revolution,
this big change in human history is called
the Neolithic Revolution. So this
Neolithic Revolution stared in central
Europe about seven and half thousand years
ago and in other parts of the world a few
thousand years earlier and a few thousand
years later. But this big change is really
the cornerstone of our modern civilization
because it provided people then with
resources that actually allow us to
sustain millions and even billions of
people today and that basically came with
this big change from this foraging
lifestyle to this early farming lifestyle.
What archeologist have debated for more
than 100 years now is whether this
change of subsistence strategy from
foraging to farming was actually related
due to the spread of ideas and culture. So
was it just cultured ideas that were
passed on from village or from region to
region or was it actually people that were
bringing agriculture to different parts of
the world. For example, to central Europe
about 7,000 years ago. So this big
question, was it pots or people that
basically then spread agriculture and into
Europe other parts of the world. And
this question is very hard to address just
based on archeological artifacts for
example or anthropological findings
because it is very difficult to really see
if biological identity of people changes
just based on archeological artifact. And
this is actually a question which is much
easier to address if we look at genetic
data. So if we look at the DNA, if we look
at the genetic make up of the people
because it makes very clear predictions
for this two different hypothesis, whether
it was ideas that were spreading during
that time or whether it was actually
people. So if we assume that ideas and
culture was for example spreading and
agriculture, we would expect that there
would be direct genetic continuity between
for example the first people that lived in
Europe, foragers 10,000 years ago, and
then the first Neolithic people and then
the people that live in Europe today. So
you would see genetic continuity if it was
just the spread of ideas. However if it
was actually people spreading agriculture,
for example, into Europe we would expect
the genetic discontinuity, something
that's called "demic diffusion," we would
actually see that people would then for
example come to Europe and change the
genetic structure so new genes would
arrive for example in Europe. And we and
many others have tried to address this
question based on mitochondria but as you
have seen in some of the previous talks,
mitochondrial DNA can be quite decisive.
So therefore we have decided then in the
last few years to actually study whole
genomes of early farmers as well as late
hunter-gatherers, so ancient foragers, to
study this question whether there was
actually genetic change of people when
agriculture was introduced to Europe, or
whether there was direct genetic
continuity. So we have sequenced genomes
of about 12 early hunter-gatherers some
years ago and combined that with data sets
that had been provided by other people,
for example like the Iceman genome. This
famous
Tyrolean mummy that was discovered a few
years ago and was actually frozen for
about 5,000 years in the Alps. As well as
a genome from a hunter-gatherer that was
found here in Spain some years ago. And we
then compared those ancient human genomes
with the genome of about 2,000 people that
come from various populations, about 200
populations in the world today with the
data set that is called the "Human
Origins" data set that is based genome
wide data of now up to 5,000 people from
many different populations in the world.
If you then take genomic data from ancient
modern people and you want to compare
that, you can imagine you have heard those
genomes are really big, there's a lot of
data and one way to break down this data
into two dimensions that you can actually
look at is a so-called principal component
analysis, where you basically take this
genetic information from all those people
and break it down into two most
informative components, principal
component one and two. And if you do that
for modern people, you get those
beautiful, colorful clouds that you see
here. And actually if you look at the
right cloud here, this cloud is actually
people that live today in Northern Africa,
in the near East as well as in the
Caucasus. We actually see this climb that
stretches from Northern Africa into the
Caucasus. Those populations here are
populations that live in Europe today. So
people that live for example in Iberia,
France, Central Europe as well as Great
Britain or Russia. What you actually see
here almost resembles geography. If you
imagine this as kind of the Northern
African coast, this is in near East, here
could be the Black Sea, this could be the
Mediterranean. So it could be an isolation
by distance, people moved into those
places and then basically genetically
slowly changed over time. However, if we
now look at our ancient individuals, our
ancient foragers as well as the early
farmers from 7,000 years ago, we first see
that our ancient foragers are genetically
actually quite distinct from the people
that live in Europe today. Now there seems
to have been not a strong continuity
between the ancient foragers and modern
Europeans. So basically no modern
Europeans that live today that looked
genetically like ancient foragers. This is
actually different for the ancient
farmers. So those 7,000 year old farmers
from Central Europe they actually do
cluster with populations that live in
Europe today. You could see this little
green cloud here. If you look at this
cloud, this is actually people that live
in Sardinia today. And this was already
discovered when the Iceman genome was
sequenced some years ago. The colleagues
actually found that the Iceman looked
genetically very similar to people that
live in Sardinia today, and that actually
made them also to hypothesize that maybe
he was some sort of tourist from Sardinia
that had gotten lost in the Alps and just
died there and froze to death. Today we
actually know that this was not quite the
case because we now have genomic data from
many early farmers, from Scandinavia, from
Iberia, from Central Europe, from Southern
Europe and they all cluster together with
Sardinians. So it is not that they all
come from Sardinia, it is rather that
modern Sardinians look genetically like
early farmers. But what you then also see
is that people that live in Europe today
are not just a simple mixture between
those ancient populations, so the foragers
and the farmers, we actually stretch all
the way up here and if you can actually
see those little diamonds up there, that
some more ancient genomes which are on
this plot that are actually populations
which we call "Ancient North Eurasians"
which are best represented by people that
lived about 10,000 20,000 years ago in
Siberia. For example, one child that was
sequenced by the group in Copenhagen from
Lake Baykal which is called the Malta
child. So you see that modern Europeans
seem to be a mixture between those three
ancient genetic populations. But what is
also very clear is that if you look at
that, neither the ancient farmer nor the
ancient forager seem to have this North
Eurasian component. This North Eurasian
one is actually quite distinct and we
wanted to find out when did this ancient
North Eurasian component arrive in
Europe. To do that, we teamed up with
David Rice's team as well as Svante Pääbo
and collected also data from the team in
Copenhagen and now put together a data set
of about 230 ancient human genomes that
span 8,000 years of European history to
see when the kind of different genetic
components over the last 8,000 years
formed. So now we actually go forward in
time starting about 8,000 years ago and
look at the genetic structure of Europe.
What you see here in the background, those
gray dots, are the modern populations and
those are the ancient individuals. So the
first thing you observe if you look at the
ancient foragers, so the indigenous
Europeans or Western Eurasians, you see
that they form this little cloud here and
that there's a gradient from the west to
the east. So this was the genetic
structure of the hunter-gatherers that
lived in Europe about 8,000 years ago. If
you look at the same time into the region
here which is Turkey today, Anatolia, you
can see that the Anatolians at that time,
they already practiced agriculture, so
they are Neolithic, so they're early
farmers. They're genetically, actually,
quite distinct from those Europeans that
lived at the same time in Europe. If we
then move ahead in the next thousand
years, agriculture comes to Europe and
suddenly when you look at the people that
lived in Europe at the time, they look
exactly like those Anatolian Neolithic
farmers. So it seems very clear now that
those Neolithic patches actually spread
with those people because Europeans
suddenly looked like that and not look
like that anymore. So there is very strong
evidence now that there was this
discontinuity of the people, that
genetically there was this large change of
people at that time period about
seven and half thousand years ago in
Central Europe. If now move in the next
2,000 years of human history in Europe, we
can actually see that the population
structure doesn't really change so much.
Genetically, people look again quite
similar to those early farmers from
Anatolia but you could actually see a
little bit of this movement in this
direction and this is indeed something
that we observe that there seems to be a
bit of genetic admixture with the
hunter-gatherers that lived in Europe at
the time, probably still in mountain
ranges and in regions where agriculture
was not favorable. So there was a bit of
genetic admixture between those early
farmers and the hunter-gatherers that were
living in Europe. However, again, this is
modern Europeans. They're not really
somewhere down here, so what's happening?
We should kind of look a bit more to the
East, and this is the same time period
that we just looked at in Central Europe
now looking at Eastern Europe so looking
at the populations which are found here,
this north of the Black Sea, or the
Caspian Sea. We can actually see that this
population which is Neolithic or Bronze
Age are steppe populations. So those are
also agriculturalists but they are not
sedentary but pastoralists, so they're
herding for example cows. And this
population is very homogenous stretching
all kind of this region here and again
they are kind of falling up here quite
distinct from the early farmers of Europe
also quite distinct from the
hunter-gatherers. And you can actually see
they are also pretty close to this
Eneolithic individuals here which are
actually late hunter-gatherers from this
region. But they are a bit more stretched
in this direction in fact and there seems
to be something hiding here and something
I don't really have the time to talk today
about but that would be a different
chapter in human history. But what's now
going on with the modern Europeans that
live today in Central Europe? When does
their genetic make up actually form? And
this is actually been happening about
4,800 years ago, 4,800 years ago and
suddenly you have a major shift in the
genetic structure of Europe. So if we move
now to this time period 4,800 years ago to
about 3,000 years ago, suddenly you have
people in Central Europe that looked like
people that live in Central Europe today.
So they are a genetic mixture of this
steppe component that we have in the
Bronze Age here in the steppe, as well as
this early and middle Neolithic people
that you had in Central Europe at that
time. So there seems to be a massive event
of migration. Suddenly you see this
massive shift and you don't only observe
that in Central Europe and in Southern
Europe but you even observe that in
Central Asia as well as in the Altai,
there seems to be a very strong evidence
now for a large migration. We can then
also quantify those genetic components in
the different populations that live in
Europe today. So those three ancestral
components the early foragers, the early
farmers, as well as this steppe
pastoralists. You can actually see there
is a climb, so populations that live in
Northern Europe today or Northeastern
Europe they have quite a high amount of
steppe ancestry and quite a low amount of
early farmer ancestry. Whereas the people
that live in Sardinia today have almost
exclusively early farmer ancestry as I've
shown you before and very, very little
ancestry here from the steppe. And if we
look at the ancient populations, you can
actually see that if you move from back in
time towards today, you can see that early
on we have this really strong component of
early farmer ancestry from Anatolia. Over
time you have a little bit of this forager
indigenous European admixture that seems
to happen over the next few thousand
years. But then 4,800 years ago we
suddenly have this green component coming
in, the steppe component. In Central
Europe we actually see about a 70%
replacement of the local agriculturalists
happening 4,800 years ago, an event that
actually no archeologists or
paleo-anthropologists had predicted so
far. So there seems to have really a mass
migration at the end of the Neolithic. So
in summary, what we can say is that
agriculture likely spread from the near
East through Anatolia into Central Europe,
starting about 7,000 to 8,000 years ago.
So it was actually people coming to Europe
introducing agriculture. What we also have
then, when the agriculturalists are
spreading in different parts of Europe or
into Scandinavia in the next 2,000 years,
Great Britain as well as to Iberia, there
seem to have a bit of genetic admixture
with the local hunter-gatherers that are
still present in Europe that time. And
then in the late Neolithic, about four and
a half to 5,000 years ago, we have this
what seems to be massive migration coming
from this region here from a culture which
is called the Yamnaya, which is
genetically extremely close with people
that have a culture which is called the
Corded Ware that stretches all the way up
to the Baltic as well into Switzerland
here and into Western Europe. So there was
this massive migration which expanded into
the West here, into Central Europe as well
as into the other direction, into the
Altai Mountains. One of the big questions
we currently have is how was that
possible? We can easily explain why there
was this first migration of agriculture to
Europe because you could imagine that
agriculture can sustain a much bigger
population so the first people that
brought agriculture to Europe probably had
a much bigger population size. But then
how was it possible that 5,000 years ago,
those early farmers were replaced by other
farmers? So what did those farmers have
when they came here that kind of made them
able to replace the people that lived in
Central Europe? And we don't really have a
good explanation currently but our
colleagues from Copenhagen recently
published a study where they could
actually find that in those people that
came to Europe, they actually found
Yersinia pestis, the causative agent of
plague, which is actually quite incredible
but it seems that during this time about
four and half thousand years ago, plague
was for the first time introduced to
Europe, potentially causing a pandemic and
you could imagine if we have a pandemic,
like for example during the Black Death
where 50% of the people in Europe died. If
something like that happened five and half
thousand years ago, it could open an
ecological niche so people could actually
move in and then replace the local
farmers. Just briefly what we could also
do is we could actually also look at the
genetic and phenotypic change through
time. We could actually look at different
phenotypes, how they change over the last
8,000 years, to look at evolution
basically and see, too. What
we saw was actually quite surprising that
the first Europeans or the Europeans that
lived about 8,000 years ago, the
hunter-gatherers, they actually had a very
distinct phenotype from people that live
in Europe today. They actually have dark
skin and blue eyes, all of them. You can
actually see that 100% frequency of those
foragers had blue eyes and dark skin. So
that actually goes down blue eyes
frequency then was the early
agriculturalists and then spreads again in
the last few thousand years. And actually
light skin that we have so typically in
Europe today is in low frequency even in
the early farmers but only starts to
spread in the Bronze Age. So this
phenotype which is so typical for
Europeans, this light skin, seems to be
only about 4,000 years old, so actually
quite a recent chapter in our evolution.
What we could also show which was quite
interesting is the ability to digest milk
during adulthood, so lactase-resistance.
That's a phenotype that a lot of people
attributed to the early agriculturalists,
that basically those people that had cows
were for sure then also able to drink a
lot of milk. But actually the frequency in
those people of this gene is actually
zero. So they didn't have it. And it only
appears then during the Bronze Age and it
really spreads only in the last 3,000
years. And we're not even sure when it
happened during antiquity, during the
Medieval time or maybe in the last few
hundred years. I'd like to end and
summarize that the Neolithic revolution is
really a diffusion of people, it was
people coming to Europe. Those people
brought genes, potentially new phenotype,
but they also brought new diseases and
that's actually quite exciting, quite
interesting the first evidence we have of
that. What we also can say now is it was
not just one migration, it was not just
those people from the near East that
brought agriculture but there was a second
large migration about 5,000 years ago.
Again, we're not really sure why it was
triggered but the introduction of diseases
is one possibility. So with that, I'd like
to thank a lot of collaboration partners
for the first paper that I mentioned,
mostly of course David Rice and his team,
but also Svante Paabo and his group in
Leipzig. The second study I presented, it
was coordinated actually with Copenhagen
and Adelaide at the time, now with us and
Yena [SP] and also David Rice's group. And
the third paper talked about which was
again coordinated by David Rice and Ian
Matterson in Harvard. I'd like to thank my
group, a lot of funding bodies. Thank you
for your attention, thank you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Maria] I was very ambitious
when I decided this title. And it's not
going to be covered all of it in 20
minutes for sure. But I'll try to cover as
much as possible and give you an idea of
what we know about the genetic history of
the Americas, mostly informed by ancient
DNA studies. So the last continent to
be...the Americas was the last continent
to be settled by humans and many questions
have been debated as to where did the
first people to enter the Americas came
from, when did they come to the
Americas, through what route, and if there
was one major or two major or three major
migrations into the Americas. So there has
been a lot of debate and attempts to
answer these questions. And many fields
have contributed to the discussion and
genetics has been very important but it
has received contributions as well from
linguistics, archeology,
paleo-anthropology, paleo-climate and
other disciplines. And it is now kind of
agreed that the first people to enter the
continent did so from Siberia, Northeast
Asia, through Beringia around 15,000 years
ago. And we set that date because the
oldest human occupation site in the
Americas is Monte Verde which is here in
Chile. And this human occupation site is
dated to 14,000 to 14,500 years old. So
the people who first entered the continent
had to do so before then and like allowing
of time for people to get here. So ancient
DNA has contributed a lot to understanding
exactly how this happened, how people
moved through the continent and where did
they come from. And we don't have
thousands or hundreds of ancient genomes,
we have only a handful from the Americas.
So I will try to give you some of the
insights that we've gained from studying
ancient Native American genomes. So the
first one is this genome from the Anzick
boy where some remains found here in
Montana and where they dated to around
12,600 years old. And they were found in
association with these fluted stone spear
points which were part of the Clovis
culture. And as far as I know, these are
the only remains that have been found in
association to these tools. So this
allowed the opportunity to investigate
like the genetic affinities of a Clovis
culture by studying the genome. When the
genome was sequenced and compared to human
populations around the globe, like
contemporary populations around the globe,
this heat map, flash map was generated
which basically shows in warmer colors the
population, each circle is a population.
So in warmer colors, you have the
populations that have the highest genetic
history sharing. So, the first thing that
was observed by sequencing this 12,000
year old individual was that most Native
Americans, basically all Native Americans
are more similar to this individual than
any other population in the world. And
most interestingly, it was found that even
though it was found like in the northern
part of the Americas, it was more closely
related or have more genetic affinity to
Central and South American contemporary
individuals, Native Americans actually.
And this already gave us an idea about
kind of the structure that was occurring
in the Americas back then. And together
with these observations and other
statistical analyses, the authors of these
study which I should mention Morten
Rasmussen who did this between Copenhagen
and Stanford. Well, they came up with this
model in which there was a divergence
predating the 12,000 years old of this
ancient genome. A divergence between the
Northern Native Americans and the Southern
Native Americans. And that Anzick would be
sitting here.
So, this genome was very
insightful in that it
gave us an idea of some
early population structure in the Americas
predating the age of this genome. And it
also gave us the idea that most Native
Americans today are descendant of a
population related to this
Clovis-associated genome. A second genome
that was sequenced just recently and
published recently and the source of a lot
of debate was that of the Kennewick Man.
The remains of this individual were found
in the Kennewick area in Washington state.
And they were dated to 8,500 years. And
there was... Again, this is a study by
Morten Rasmussen. This was a source of a
lot of controversy because the first
analysis on the skeletal remains and
particularly on the morphology of the
skull. So the scientists who did this
first analysis they said that the
morphology of the skull was more similar
to contemporary individuals of Southeast
Asia and Polynesians. So, what that led
to was the owners of the land, which was
actually the US Army, not giving the
remains to the Native American tribes who
were claiming these remains for reburial.
And that was just based on the scientist
who drew these conclusions on the
morphology of the skull alone. So of
course, there was a lot of scientific
debate. And because the first attempts to
extract DNA were unsuccessful, there was a
lot of controversy and litigation for many
years, at least nine years. But finally
this group in Copenhagen, they're very
good at this, were given the opportunity
to try again to do some genetic analysis.
And they were able to sequence an entire
genome of the Kennewick Man. So the very
first observation is that it actually
falls within Native American variation,
just like that. And so this is a BCA plot
similar to what Johannes just showed. And
these are contemporary Native Americans,
these are populations from the rest of the
world, this is Europe. So, that was the
first result, this individual is Native
American. And when looking at the genetic
affinities within America, it was shown
something similar to what was shown for
the Anzick individual. It shares more
genetic history with Central, North and
South Americans than with other Native
Americans from the North, even though it
was found here. But it was also
interesting to find that tribes for the
same area where the Kennewick Man was
found, also shared a high level of genetic
ancestry with the Kennewick Man. So this
was like another piece of evidence about
the past genetic structure in the
Americas. So again, with this observation
and more sophisticated statistical
methods, what this study proposed was
that, so this was the original branching
between Northern Native Americans and
Southern Native Americans. The Anzick sits
here as an ancestor to modern South and
Central Native Americans. But there was
another branching here, and Kennewick is
here, that gave rise to Pacific Northwest
Native Americans. But there was a follow
by some gene flow from East Asia that
probably obscures a little bit the genetic
affinity of the Kennewick to the Pacific
Northwest Native Americans. So this was a
very important contribution and not only
gave us insights about the past genetic
structure of the Americas, but it also
helped resolve this controversy about
whether Kennewick Man was Native American
or not. And now, just an additional report
supporting this was published
three days ago probably.
So we could hopefully put an end
to this litigation and these
remains...well, we don't know because many
tribes are claiming the remains so maybe
there will be yet another debate. But
anyway, this is what we learned from the
scientific standpoint. And the third
genome I will tell you about is this from
the Saqqaq Paleo-Eskimo, which is very
interesting because it was sequenced from
a tuft of hair and this hair was preserved
for around 4,000 years in the present
permafrost in Southwest Greenland. And
this is an artistic reconstruction of the
individual based on genotype, like
phenotypic information that was taken from
the genome that was sequenced. So this was
actually the first ancient human genome to
be sequenced and again, this was done in
Copenhagen by Morten Rasmussen and
colleagues. So what we learned about this
genome was also very interesting. So the
Saqqaq individual was found here but the
genetic affinity surprisingly, or not to
some, are not to modern contemporary
Greenlanders. So this individual is
genetically more similar to individuals
from Siberia like Chukchi and Koryaks
here. So what this indicated is that there
was probably a past migration like
predating 4,000 years ago, probably 5,000
to 6,000 years, a migration from Northeast
Asia to the Americas that was later
replaced by a population that gave rise to
modern day Inuits. So these are like three
single genome studies, but thanks to the
development in next generation sequencing
we have been able to generate now multi-
or... Well, yes, complete or semi-complete
genomes from different individuals more
than just one at a time. So we generated
some genomic data from multiple
individuals to test one particular
hypothesis. This was part of a larger
study but my contribution was testing
this Paleo-American relics hypothesis.
So, again, based on this morphology of the
skull, it was suggested that the very
first people to enter the Americas and for
which we have remains like for example,
Lucia from the Lagoa Santa and
the Penan] woman which are really,
really old, that the morphology of this
skull is more similar to present day
people from Melanesia. Some scientists
suggest that there was a first migration
of people with this Paleo-American skull
that was later replaced completely by
Siberia, like the first migration I
mentioned. And that there was a complete
wipeout and replacement. But that there
were some relic populations because based
on the morphology of the skull of some
individuals who are in isolated parts of
the continent like the Pericos in the tip
of Baja, California and the
Fuego-Patagonians here, these had a
particular skull morphology that resembles
also Austra-Melanesians. So this was a
theory and we wanted to test it. So we
sequenced partial genomes from 17
individuals from these supposedly a relict
populations. And what we found, we
were actually expecting this already, was
that they all fall within Native American
variations, so there was no evidence of
any connection to Austra-Melanesia
whatsoever. But more interestingly is that
we observe a genetic continuity with
modern populations in the same geographic
area. For example, the people from
Fuego-Patagonia in PCA space, they fall in
proximity to present day Fuego-Patagonians
from Chile, so they [inaudible 00:52:26]
from Chile. And similar in Mexico. The
Pericos from Mexico not only fell within
the native variation in Mexico, but they
did so with Northern population from
Mexico. So we were able to pin down that
they were very closely similar to
Tarahumara and Purépecha which are
Northern Native groups in Mexico. Well,
first we just disprove this idea of relict
Paleo-Americans. And secondly we
demonstrated that there is this genetic
continuity. And actually we observed this
in many samples now, in many genomes that
have been sequenced. And we observed so,
as I showed a little bit with the
Kennewick Man that had genetic affinity to
populations from the same geographic area.
But we've observed through almost 8,000
years so we have different genomes from
different ages here. And what we've
observed continuously is that there seems
to be this genetic continuity in the
Americas, and that is in contrast with
what Johannes just showed of these massive
demographic shifts. So the Americas, at
least Central and South America, the
Northern part seems to be a bit more
complex, but at least Central and South
have been kind of very stable for many
thousands of years, so that's interesting.
A question that hasn't been resolved quite
yet is if there were three or two
migration waves into the Americas.
Different groups with different data sets
from modern populations support one or the
other. So there is one model that...there
was one major migration that gave rise to
most Native Americans followed by a second
and a third that were mostly just Northern
Native Americans. And there is another
model that instead of suggesting a second
migration, suggests that there was
divergence within America of a Northern
and a Southern branch and that this
occurred within America approximately
13,000 years ago. And something that has
been a bit puzzling for us who study
genetic diversity in the Americas is the
observation by two independent studies of
something that looks like gene flow from
Austra-Melanesians or Papua New Guinians,
or population related to contemporary
Papua New Guinians and Melanesians, into
populations in the Amazonian, like the
Xavante, Suruí and Karitiana. And two
independent studies have identified this
signal, although yet we don't have a good
explanation of how or when this happened.
So it's very puzzling actually. And just
for the last part, I want to make the
point that so far I just talked about the
peopling of the Americas but there's
actually much more genetic history in the
recent 15,000 years of course. So I think
we can use ancient DNA to investigate, or
a combination of ancient and modern DNA,
to investigate other regional aspects of
the history of the Americas. An example
here, for example is the peopling of the
Caribbean. By it's location you can argue
it could have been people from Florida,
from the Yucatan peninsula or from South
America. And now combining data from
modern population, modern Caribbean
population and studying the Native
American fraction of this population and
comparing to reference panel of Native
Americans, it has been suggested that it
was people, actually, by South America
here, facilitated by the Orinoco River.
And we have been able to
kind of prove this with
ancient genomes from Taino genomes. And
I'm just showing here an example of one
sample from Cuba, from Chorro de Maita,
Cuba which also falls in the genetic
variation of Arawakan speakers, like
Wahiro, Piapoco and Ticuna. So this is
another way we're complimenting
information from modern and ancient
population to resolve a question about the
particular event in history. And I'm also
doing something on the same lines. I don't
have the time to tell you more about it
but we're doing something similar in the
peopling of the Patagonia, like the very
last part that was people in the Americas.
And lastly, I want to make the point that
we can also use ancient DNA even in
historical times, but for events in
history where the historical record is
sparse. So, I'll just show you an example
where we used ancient DNA to learn about
the past history of people brought to the
Americas as a result of the Trans-Atlantic
Slave Trade. You can argue that there is
historical records about this, but this
exact origins of people in Africa that
were brought to the Americas that was
basically not recorded, it's kind of
absent in the historical record. So we can
also use ancient DNA to reconstruct some
of this history. So in this, very quickly,
it was a pilot study where we had three
individuals from the Caribbean and we
wanted to know where in Africa were they
from. They were found in the same burial
site. And by comparing to a reference
panel in Africa, we sequenced fractions of
their genomes, we were able to find that
one of them was more closely related to
Bantu-speaking populations. And two of
them were more closely related to
non-Bantu-speaking populations and we had
evidence to argue that this three people
were put in the same embarkation and
brought to the Americas together. But we
are really missing information about how
culturally diverse were the people who
were brought from Africa to the Americas.
So, just to summarize, most Native
Americans...because I went through
something very general like the peopling
of the Americas to something super
specific about an episode in history. But
I want you to take this messages home. So
most Native Americans trace their
ancestry to a single migration from East
Asia to Beringia between 15,000 and 20,000
years ago. If there was one, two or three
subsequent migration is still under
debate. There is evidence of ancient gene
flow from population related to
Austra-Melanesians into some Amazonian
populations, although we don't know
exactly how that happened. The sequencing
of ancient genomes from the Americas has
complimented the knowledge generated from
studying genome-wide data from modern
populations. But we still have very few
compared to Europe, for example. And this
last point, it's also something very
important for me, ancient DNA research can
also be useful for investigating other
aspects apart from the initial peopling of
the continent. I think we put too much
attention into that that we've forgotten
about the more recent history or
pre-history, like the source populations
in Africa of the people who were brought
during the Trans-Atlantic Slave Trade. And
with that I'll complete. And thank
you.
♪ [music] ♪